great hi guys George Davis founder and
CEO frame day I my talk here is on bias
variance and data products I'm going to
explain what that means in a second but
I hope everyone has merely had their
appetites wet for discussing data
products by the great keynote we just
had I'm going to talk a little bit more
about practitioner work and and how we
actually go about building teams and
informing those teams to build data
products but first just a little bit
about me or more accurately about my
company so framed AI is a conversational
technology startup focused on improving
business conversations and especially
ones that have multiple people in the
loop so not replacing people but finding
ways to augment the conversations
they're already having especially if
those conversations need to be informed
by a substantial amounts of data and
then finally recognizing this as one
part of a complex relationship that
involves a lot of touch points between
these people and that's actually about
all I'm going to say about us we're
keeping a pretty low profile through the
end of the year and most of what I'm
going to talk about is things that have
actually been on my mind for a long time
as I discovered and started working on
data products and maybe are things that
you've run into as well and let me just
ask to start with how many people here
are currently working on data products
as opposed to other kinds of operational
data science okay I see a lot of hands
half up is that maybe there's like
ambiguity about what data product mean
in my case I'm talking about systems
where they're making decisions that are
informed by and determined by
substantial amounts of data that might
not even be available at the time that
you're designing the product and this is
actually something that's been happening
for a really long time so well before i
discovered the term data science i was
chasing data around and i'm sure many of
us were under the guise of scientific
computing and we found these in early
technologies like network analysis
search bioinformatics gps and logistical
analytics automated trading and it
wasn't until I kind of poked my head out
of the automated trading world and went
to Newton where I headed up data science
before starting framed out AI that I
realized that this
we were living through I had this forest
gump moment that something really
fundamental had changed about my career
which I thought was pretty much set
which was teaching computers to do to
make scientific inferences from data and
what had changed was there were suddenly
consumers who were extremely aware of
the data that we had about them they
were aware of the value that could be
produced by products that utilized that
data and they were starting to form
expectations and companies that want to
deliver these products needed people to
help manage those expectations and
understand what the data actually could
do for them and so this data science
term which when I first encountered I
thought of it as just kind of just a
branding thing sorry DJ and Jeff but the
need for branding was very important
because you we suddenly needed to be
able to set and maintain user
expectations and they and users needed
someone to blame when those expectations
weren't met and I think blame is
actually the right word in a lot of
cases so I've got blurbs up here from
five incredible products these are
products that objectively do amazing
things and yet they have failure modes
that are very common knowledge very well
publicized and get a lot of specific
derision it's because if you have a
system that does objectively amazing
things but then sometimes does
objectively stupid things it's very easy
for people to focus on the ladder it's
much easier to lose trust than to build
it and so the process of escaping these
we need new processes for building
products that escape these traps and
that set expectations as well as we
possibly can and many of us I think in
this room are either part of those
processes are designing those processes
or at least at the other end of them I
think one of the things that causes a
lot of complication in the development
of data products and in the set of a
setting of expectations is that data
products inherently violate one of the
key principles of product design which
is principle of least surprised in some
ways of a data product isn't capable of
surprising you if it's not learning
something from the data that you
couldn't have defined opera or e then
it's not really doing its job
and so whereas when you're developing a
traditional product you tend to have one
at major axis of complexity in terms of
user behaviors that you have to worry
about and that's between convention and
configuration so there's some parts of
your product that our common experience
for everyone and that's a very simple
way relatively to design a product
because you just have one set of
behaviors that you have to make sure
meet people's expectations and then
configuration where you actually have
people able to use the product in very
different ways and express their own
needs and have a different product
experience and even with just this one
access it can be very hard to design
good products if you if too much is
configurable it's very hard for users to
understand how to use it it's very hard
for you to think through all of the edge
cases of how someone might miss
configure your product and have a bad
expectation that they blame you for data
products add an entire new axis of
complexity to this problem the fact that
some of your behaviors determine by data
instead of instead of an advanced means
even if you have one user experience
being informed by that data if it's the
result of an optimization process you
might be surprised by what your system
ends up doing if it's an if you're
actually going for a DAP tivity so if
you're separating out some portions of
the data that apply to individual users
and you're giving them a different
experience based on their based on their
particular data path through your
product then all of a sudden you have
this multiplication of the types of
complexity that you have to worry about
and a lot of the failure modes that I
put on the slide before I think are
cases where people had their people were
in edge cases of these combinations of
complexity that the designers hadn't
anticipated so how do we start trying to
think about anticipating those well
since I'm coming from a data science
background so the three roles here data
scientists data engineer product manager
these are pretty new factorization of
this problem I'm actually curious how
many people in this room that consider
would identify as a data scientist ok
this is the data science track that
makes sense what about a data engineer
ok lots of overlap makes sense what
about product managers
yes alright you have to tell me which
parts of this I got right and wrong at
the end but the and what about other
functions business roles etc all right
so factoring because I'm a data
scientist I think of this as sort of a
factored optimization problem we're all
working I don't know how readable that
actually is but we're all working to
maximize the expected value that a user
retrieves from our product perhaps minus
some cost of what it took us to deliver
that can measure cut or maybe some of
the costs that they took and coming into
the product by manipulating different
parts of the product that we own so the
product manager might own the
expectations they might set some of the
engineering affordances the data
scientists might determine the model
that's available the data engineers
might be developing the systems that
determine which data is available for
the model so we each own these
parameters and we're working together to
optimize these functions but in many
cases it's not just the parameters we
own but we're only expertise in
evaluating an aspect of this function so
the the data engineers are in a best
position to understand what the costs in
terms of a development cycle of adding
certain day of reaching certain
engineering affordances are or making
certain types of data available the data
scientist is more or less responsible
for understanding the probabilistic
aspect of the behavior what's the
distribution of your users if we make
these choices what kind of distribution
of experiences are people actually going
to get and the product manager is
usually responsible for understanding
what the value of those experiences is
to the user and because this is
incredibly high dimensional space nobody
really owns an ala a map of their of
even their entire space at best we can
kind of evaluate our functions maybe
communicate a few gradients and when we
go through training documents between
each other or testing each other's work
we're basically doing this partial
gradient descent on this function where
each of us try to improve our little
locus of the product and one consequence
of that is because all parts have to be
able to to act it to move forward is
that we get blocked all the time so you
know data engineer can block a data
scientist by making data inaccessible
not operationalize and the way they
expected it so they
to go back through and clean it product
manage data scientists can block a
product manager by having unproduced
behaviors that weren't predicted and
then follow keep them from delivering
value to the customer and pretty much
everyone in here along the main diagonal
allows themselves to be blocked if
they're not capable of stepping outside
their function if they can't actually if
they need to await sort of a perfect
input from their collaborators in order
to render some opinion or take a step
forward on their part of the process so
this is a very fragile process there's
so many ways here and anything that goes
wrong on one of these lists can end up
blocking the other ones so how do we
make it less fragile well one thing we
can think about doing is only hiring
triple unicorns what if we owe what if
everybody we hired can do all these
roles and they just understand
everything about the product that would
be really nice if you find any of those
let me know this is kind of mostly
joking but it's but there's a serious
aspect to this which is when I'm hiring
one of the main things I focus on it as
soon as I know that someone has
something to contribute that they have
some that they have some talent that
extends the capabilities of the team
almost everything else is is this person
on blockable can are we hiring someone
who knows enough about their interface
points to you know do too etl their own
way out of a data deficiency and so on
so there's that aspect when you're
building your team another one is
sitting together this really simple
thing that and it's one of these things
if you've always been doing it it's
completely obvious but surprising how
many people don't do it a lot of people
actually prefer to sit in functional
roles they get to exchange best
practices they get to think about career
paths but if you're going to iterate on
this problem quickly you need to have up
to the moment access to each other and
so actually putting teams that have to
do this into a configuration where they
can execute a tight loop is a really
important decision that you have to make
when designing your product teams and
then the final one which is really the
focus of this talk is communicating
trade-offs not evaluations so if you try
to do a gradient descent where each of
these people is only communicating
we're their function is based on the
choices other people have made then you
won't be able to move forward very
quickly but if you can communicate to
each other something about the
directionality and the trade-offs that
you're currently facing right now on
your function then they can make some
choices thinking for you and thinking
thinking around your problems and
everyone can move forward faster and so
the talk is really about these three
concepts that I think are good
especially for data scientists to
communicate in terms of the trade-offs
that affect their role and your I had
this cute idea to base these on
statistical properties and you'll have
to tell me how stretch they are later
but the first one is bias variance
trade-off and I picked this one
partially as an excuse to show my
favorite cartoon from all statistics
which is what's are not a funny cartoon
but a very explanatory cartoon so this
is showing us how decisions about our
model space and whether we pick more or
less bias models affect the amount of
variants that our model actually ends up
producing and so the red line reflects a
very expressive model that has the
capability to come much closer to
expecting the app the actual truth of
the underlying distribution the purple
line here is a model that is in some
sense more wrong it can't come anywhere
near as close to actually encompasses
true distribution but it is much more
opinionated about what kind of
distributions that might see and as a
result even though it's not as
objectively accurate as the other model
it varies a lot less when the data it
receives varies and that's very
important to this principle of least
surprised argument because it allows you
it's much easier to calibrate user
expectations to a behavior that's not
ideal than it is to calibrate user
expectations to not having any idea what
the behavior will be so in plain English
the version of this trade-off is to keep
in mind that the value your model
produces is the product of the
availability of plentiful data about the
thing that you're studying make the good
assumptions your model makes about what
what shape it's what the form of it's
trying to find and the data is and the
tolerance for error in which the model
is deployed and so if you're short on
any one of these things you better be
very very long and the other ones that's
what the bias-variance trade-off tells
you from a practical business
perspective and I think this is
something that everyone involved in data
products should know and sort of have in
the back of their heads whether you're
at the business level whether your
investor etc and nine times out of ten
we try to solve this at the business
level by making sure that we're doing
something that's going to have access to
a lot of data I actually think that's an
interesting I think there's a lot of
interesting problems that we're going to
be discovering that are more about
medium sized data that large data as
opposed to big data in the near future
but even when you have maneuvered
yourself we're into a place where you
have access to large amounts of data
about a problem you have places where
sparsity can sneak in few data sets are
large in every way that matters so on
the left here we've got a guy who is
about to experience his first black
friday if your data set has some form of
seasonality that you have not yet
experienced you have an opportunity for
an enormous amount of surprise coming
down the pipe at the top right if I'm
trying to find a leash for my dog pet
puppy cat kitty then amazon might put
right up next to each other to force to
our products one of whom which has 2000
reviews and the other one has 32
reasonable choice hard to know how to
compare these really just pointing out
here that any individual object in your
data set might have be at the beginning
of its life and there might be very
little data about that particular object
so you have to think about every life
cycle of a data entity and then finally
even in a data set that's matured where
you where you have a stable and and your
product has been in the market for a
long time and you have a stable system
that you're providing value to you can
have these power loss affects humans
love to produce power loss facts because
we kind of follow each other and we
chase each other and we attach
preferentially and so if you're the
arrows are a little bit off here but if
you're delivering if this is your social
network very mature lots of people the
experience of someone on your new feed
product is going to be very different if
there's somewhere near the core of this
network as opposed to someone near the
periphery
and hope that most of the people here
have done this but if you have friends
who kind of live at the periphery of
Facebook it's definitely worth taking
our family it's worth taking a chance to
look at how different the product
experience is of a lot of the things
that you might take for granted
especially when front windows first come
out so so even in very large data sets
you can have sparsity that can really
affect behaviors for some people so how
do we solve this and this is something
I'm going to do for each of these is I'm
going to talk about some very well-known
examples of companies solving this in
ways that I think are pretty good and
one of em categorizing them so one of
them here is when you have a low amount
when you have an area of sparse data
failover to a high bias model so on the
Left I thought this google search result
was very interesting when I when I can
repeat my cat leash search if I've just
typed cat in an incognito window where I
haven't already searched for cat leashes
a hundred times it's kind of a hobby
then google it biases towards a set of
returns that has a very high diversity
in interpreting the word cat so if you
look closely at those first three
examples cat makeup is using it in the
sense of the animal in other cases it's
the first three letters of a place or
the first three letters of a company
that I might be looking for information
on and so on but even after I've
searched for cat leash once and it's
remembered in my history not only is it
an explicit product featured to remind
me that I actually searched for this but
the subsequent returns assume that usage
pattern so the experience changes as you
accumulate data about the kinds of cat
oriented searches I perform another
example here is when you create a new
account on Amazon most of us who have
been buying books on amazon for a long
time have enough history that things are
lumped into a very generic recommended
for you category that's presented in
some case in this case amazon has
accurately identified that with the
one-year-old son at home i like to buy
books about mealtime a little horse and
advanced programming in the unix
environment on the other hand with an
incognito account that had done nothing
except click on a single link it failed
over to a model that had many fewer
degrees of freedom
so it instead in the same slot presents
the you viewed i am brian wilson and as
a result shows me a bunch of other
musician by optics the anchoring that
suggestion on one on on a single action
makes for mini few of a model with many
fewer parameters and then they even
explain their bias by by telling me
exactly why i'm getting this
recommendation final thing you can do
about this is accepting and
communicating the variance this is
actually the thing I see most rarely
maybe because in most commercial
arrangements people just don't accept
much variance there's not many things
where we are okay not knowing what we're
paying for what product we're going to
get it disturbs the unit economics of a
lot of relationships but on shipping we
accept this and so you know for a
shipper that either hasn't had there's
not much shipping data about their
performance on delivering cat leashes or
perhaps they just are very unreliable I
might accept the nine Nova a six day
window to receive this leash in exchange
for these ninety nine percent positive
review ratings they have but I'm also
presented with this low variance option
if I really need it between november
seventh and tenth i can get it from wag
calm and instead of happy dog please so
accepting and communicating variance is
also a technique I think works much more
often for internal products when you're
making projections when you're making
predictions that are going to be
interpreted inside a company there's
more of an opportunity to discuss the
variability in your prediction all right
next topic precision recall so this
section is mostly about thinking about
user trust and how you maintain it while
you improve your product over time so
everybody there's lots of hands went up
for data scientists expect everyone's
familiar with precision recall but just
to recap on the precision side we have
the idea that every time we sound an
alarm it should be accurate precision is
how many of your total positives are
true positive whereas recall is well if
something bad happens you definitely
want to sound the alarm and you don't
mind having some false positives to do
it so
so is the percentage of total positives
of true positives out of all true and in
many cases we have to make product
decisions about a trade-off between
these even if we have a very good model
we have to predict the confidence of the
model at which we actually perform
certain activities and I'm going to
suggest that in many cases it's the
extremes of these decisions that are
most valuable for customers and it's
because they have they create a behavior
that is very understandable and very
predictable so in as an everyday example
if I'm a bike messenger I want to make
sure that every time someone might run
into me they hear my bell and I don't
care how many people who aren't going to
run into me also hear my bell so I
execute a very high recall policy on
every time somebody might run into me
with even a small probability ringing
that Bell whereas if I'm a spam filter
the cost of a false positive for spam is
very very high I don't want to actually
get rid of that email so I need a lot of
precision and it's okay if a few if a
few bad email is actually get through in
a single page of Google search results
we can see some really examples of both
of these in these products so on the on
the ad returns and on the search results
we can see the need for high recall
products you want to absolutely make
sure that if there is a relevant ad
you're going to show it and you want to
make sure that if there are relevant
items on the Internet I guess that's
kind of an old version of this problem
that they come up but then you have
these other features these knowledge
graph features that that take up a huge
amount of the screen real estate and you
only want to do that you only want to
replace your ads and search results with
these features if they have a very very
high utility and so you need a very high
precision for a behavior like that and I
think one of the things that's very
interesting about this behavior is that
it is one where the absence of the
product doesn't actually eliminate the
user experience and that gives you some
flexibility in how your product develops
if you can engineer your product in such
a way that the data product is a nice to
have and a value add but there's some
baseline experience
that's supported if your data feature
can't add value then you can afford to
take a stance where you can pick up
threshold a very high recall or very
high precision and iterate and and
release your product early to begin
valid at the beginning gaining data but
maintain this level of trust that when a
user actually sees your product
interfere they know and they can trust
that the thing they're being told is
useful to them and then iterating over
time on how frequently you can provide
that value so you start with very high
recall and add precision over time
you'll you have one type of user trust
if you start with very high precision
and add recall over time that you have
another and a good example of this you
know I first started seeing those cards
in my own google searches five or six
years ago and now i see them all the
time and i found a statistic that about
a third of google searches actually have
these knowledge graph instances i think
that's a case of a product being
released very subtly collecting a lot of
data and being able to maintain trust as
it added to the experience over time and
now i can find out very easily that the
steelers mascot is Steely mattt beam
which i had no idea about even though i
lived in pittsburgh for nine years so so
precision recall something for binary
classifiers but this obviously applies
to lots of other kinds of data products
to the very general plain english
version is discuss the relative costs of
different kinds of errors in your data
product very early and very often if you
have if at the heart of your data
product is a multi-class classification
problem you can think about a cost
matrix if it's more of a prediction
problem that's open-ended you can think
about a cost function what's important
is that that team of three people the
engineer the product manager and the
data scientist are discussing an hour
where of the trade-offs when their model
makes one kind of error versus another
all right last topic here this one
doesn't have a good statistical analogy
or at least one that was highly
recognizable but I wanted to talk a
little bit about coevolution so I've set
this up as an optimization problem that
happens inside your company these people
and and when we talked about trust we
kind of started to think about how the
actions inside of your company affect
your users but the other dimension to
this is that
your users are actually going to
co-evolved along with your product so
depending on what kind of value you're
able to offer to them you're going to
get certain they're going to have
certain learn behaviors that they feed
back into your product and that can
reach some equilibriums that have a big
effect on the experience of the product
for everyone and it's not completely in
your control a really good example of
this that came out is this great study
very relevant to a lot of people lately
of the red feed blue feed this idea that
people tend to group into social is
because people group into social groups
that have a lot of agreement there's a
filter bubble where they experience
content that mostly agrees with them but
what's striking to me is not that
because you can make an argument about
whether how natural this dichotomy is to
begin with what's striking is that you
can see its effect on the content we
have we have content that's really in
like forwarded with the assumption that
people always ready agree with it so
rather than being sort of persuasive
content it is emotional and and a
content that engages people who already
hold a certain point of view on top of
that that may be a reason is not that
your intended product experience for
your users another part is that you may
inherently need your experience users to
keep expected having novel experiences
in order to get value out of your
product so for Spotify if everyone was
left to their own devices and only had
an only listen to the same 20 albums for
their entire life it would be hard for
them to put a lot of value on a giant
music collection but if they keep
discovering new things and are an hour
and are continuously reminded of how big
the world of new music is and how much
they enjoy it then maybe they can put a
higher value there and so there's some
very interesting work leaking out a
little bit at a time there about how
they jointly optimized for preferences
and novelty so in this case this was a
quartz article that discussed sort of
the multimodal nature of the preference
space that users have and how the and
how a playlist generated by the Spotify
weekly makes use of all these multiple
modes of preferences while also
selecting for things that are not too
similar to tracks they've listened to
before so you can make a model that
jointly optimizes for people's
preferences and their immediate
satisfied
for the novelty of their experience
Netflix had another approach which they
publicized on their blog about this
which was very interesting which was
essentially treating incentivizing
novelty as this entire additional
problem so separate from whatever we do
in terms of ranking searches when we do
show a content to a user how can we make
them how can we especially invest in
making them interested in content that's
new that they necessarily don't have any
familiarity with before and they did
that by generating a lot of different
types of user experiences and testing to
optimize which content was shown to
incentivize people to try a new product
even varying it by different region so
in this case it was discovered that for
the very same material you could get
people to try it out for the first time
substantially with substantially
different effects if you used these
different posters in these different
countries and there's some very good
academic work now coming out that's also
about making explicit incentivization
mechanisms built into your product for
for incentivising novelty so just to
kind of sum up and review some of these
the the main folk the main things I
wanted people to walk away with our that
you can increase the performance of your
product of your data product teams a by
mapping the edges of the data and
understanding how they're going to
evolve over time thinking about that
data through time and planning for the
low data regions for the low data
experiences of your product to be met
with high bias models or the
communication of variants that lets
people have and a user experience that's
still within their expectation secondly
it's very important not to treat all
errors is equal and it's if there's not
a lot of communication between a product
manager team and a data science team it
can be very hard to know what the real
error function behind that you should be
optimizing is when you design your
models so compare different kinds of
error impacts early and often and think
about targeting specific limitations on
specific types of errors so that you can
at least make some confident promises to
your customers and improve on other
types of value of time finally track and
plan on user
adapting to your product and there are
creative ways there's ways that we can
help you know a lot of times data
science is being blamed right now for
this filter bubble and for these
algorithmic potholes that systems get
stuck in but there's ways that we can
help break out of those potholes to
communicating about these fundamentals
helps everyone on the team's think ahead
about the product and each other's
functions and not get blocked there's
lots of other good reading about this so
classic DJ patel's building data science
teams old but still great margot swimmer
had a had a great article a few years
ago about drivetrain a drivetrain
approach to building data products from
Kaggle a nutella on from intuit
presented at Grace Hopper this year on
the product playground that's very
that's a talk that's essentially a
product managers version of this talk
and it's very interesting has some great
Star Trek metaphors and then just
recently DJ Patel again in first round
what we wish we'd known about developing
adaptive data products for the
government all great all great
additional perspectives on this if
you're building out your team and your
practices and that's it for me so thanks
let's talk about this or conversational
commerce in AI or anything else you want
to talk about in the office hours also
the obligatory we are hiring jobs at a
frame day I if you're interested if you
want to know what we're doing don't
hesitate to reach out